it wasn't long ago that NFL rookie
contracts just kept going up and up and
up but times have changed
football has become all of a sudden not
all that exciting of business in terms
of representation of rookies the NFL's
2011 collective bargaining agreement
drastically roll back rookie salaries
and furthermore our cost with regard to
training the players and moving them
around has continued to escalate the
agent is now obligated to pay for the
training of an NFL player which can cost
ten to twenty thousand dollars per
player the 2011 labor deal also lowered
the cap on agent fees we used to be a 4%
max now it's the 3% max of course the
agents can charge as little as they
would as they can stand the difficulty
has been some of our competition
reducing their fees by up to 50% now
they're competitively going down and why
pay more for an agent when salaries are
set with little bargaining room the
first contract has really become
standardized in all sports wage scale
prefabricated contracts a 7 year old
could negotiate it as well as a top
agent back in the days when I was doing
voidable years avoid buybacks and we
were creating new concepts you really
could get an athlete much more money
than the player proximate to them not
today this is a hard cap when you get to
the second contracts now we're talking
about nuance now we're talking about
structure now we're talking about
differences you talked about the real
money in sports that's the second
contract you have to somehow keep the
relationship through the first four or
in the case of first rounders five years
to get to the more profitable contracts
so as an entry-level like moth to the
flame agents still try to do football
but breaking in on the working fronts a
really daunting task
hmm